the guys sound great and are hitting the
road for the first time in three years
for their by two K to earth
after the crazy fans are still there I
mean are they crazy fans that are 16
they're now older or still 16 year old
girls it's it's a combination of both
this coolest blue continue to look out
and see some of your loyal fans who are
now bringing their own daughters to your
show and say hey this is you know this
is what mom is let's do when she was
your age and it's a cool kind of passing
the torch moment that happens in a lot
of these shows
oh yeah this boyband even covered Billy
Joel's PG was with the guys from Ohio
during their rise to fame so our senior
news editor Jennifer Pyro's just had to
share with them a little beauty
flashback Friday
this concert seemed a little like Magic
Mike we spoke to the guys at 1010 wins
radio adorama live theater in new york
and it was fun throwing it back with
them looking at those nine these
fashions mechanics what's more read the
jumpsuit on my face
who knows maybe nick swipin acid it's
the retro luck the two our parents - two
small kids but they won't be touring
with daddy are you bring the family on
for uh no actually none of us are
bringing our families on the road this
time it's just it's just us on a tour
bus like the old days where the craziest
fan experience I have ever experienced
we have a crazy fan pose as and someone
that was interviewing us one time and
had a cameraman with there